a month ago dr robert maxwell was a
senior researcher working at the
facility but a tragic mistake had cost
the lives of several of his
co-researchers now he was being led down
a bleak hallway in armed bio-containment
area 14 a rifle wielding guard flanking
him on either side the once rising
researcher had a very different title
now d
8724
he had been made a d-class personnel
a death sentence
however as the guards led him to his
possible demise he wasn't dressed in the
typical d-class orange jumpsuit no he
was dressed in frilly rococo dining wear
more typical of 18th century france if
anything dr maxwell looked like he was
on his way to meet royalty
and in a sense he was
the former researcher had begged for any
other assignment but the site director
insisted on committing dr maxwell to tea
time with scp-082
he'd always been the talkative type so
the two would make a perfect pairing and
if the creature found him sufficiently
amusing then maxwell might even leave
the containment cell alive he had heard
legends of the giant creature they
called the cannibal
maxwell hoped they were just stories
dr maxwell was pushed by the guards into
a large luxuriously appointed room and
the doors were locked behind him he felt
like a child surrounded by freakishly
large furniture and 10-foot high
ceilings the fog of obnoxious floral
perfumes couldn't fully cover up the
pervasive smell of death that lingered
in the cavernous halls of 082's palace
thanks to an elaborate ruse conducted by
the foundation
scp-082 believed he was the king of
france and that his containment cell was
a palace where he remained for his own
safety the creature's continued good
behavior and everyone else's safety
relied on visitors keeping up that lie
maxwell had never worked in this area of
the facility so a lot of the standard
procedures were new to him still his
superior had given him a clear directive
talk to the monster communicate with him
be cordial and friendly see if you can
find out more about his mysterious past
and most importantly if you want to
survive
don't annoy him the down-on-his-luck
scientist gulped inside
trying to steady his nerves in this
oversized fake french palace
he just kept thinking surely he can't be
that big he almost talked himself into
believing that the accounts of the
creature were just that tall tales until
a huge figure began lumbering into the
main chamber it was him
scp-082
also known as fernand the cannibal
scp-082 was an eight-foot tall hulking
monster built sturdier than the castles
it likes to imagine are its true home
swollen bloated and grossly out of
proportion the creature clocks in at
over 700 pounds
most of which is pure muscle that's
almost impossible to pierce with
conventional weaponry
scp-082 stopped just feet away and
stared at dr maxwell with its beady
sunken in eyes like a hungry rat
just the sight of it struck terror into
dr maxwell's heart but he didn't dare
show his fear
instead he remembered his brief training
bowing politely and forcing a smile
referring to the creature as your
highness and profusely thanking it for
granting him an audience
the monster continued staring without
saying anything and then gave a wide
lock-jawed grin showing off its huge
teeth it did everything through gritted
teeth except eat and sing
dr maxwell hoped he wouldn't be a part
of either activity
fernand gave a low booming chuckle he
thanked dr maxwell for coming to give
him some company and invited him to come
further inside and take a seat adding
with a sly wink that he won't bite the
monster complained that he so rarely
gets visitors to the palace these days
but he omitted the fact that the main
reason for this was his tendency to
devour them
maxwell nodded and followed the giant
deeper into its oversized abode he
couldn't help but notice that the
monster's arms looked like huge fleshy
punching bags he knew that if fernand
wanted to he could easily crush him flat
just like he done to so many unfortunate
guards during containment breaches
fernand told dr maxwell that he was
thinking of having some decorating work
done the walls of his palace were
starting to look awfully drab and he
gestured to one covered with a rusty red
streak maxwell remembered that d-class
cleaners were sent into the containment
cell twice a month to tidy any of
ferdinand's messes but they often ended
up becoming one of the messes themselves
the creature encouraged maxwell to take
a seat at his oversized dining table
while he tended to a pot of what he said
was full of delicious onion soup maxwell
obliged his host's request and took a
seat at a huge chair that made him look
like a six-year-old sitting at the
grown-ups table
meanwhile ferdinand was using a huge
machete-like knife to cleave onions in
half for his bubbling pot of stew even
though ferdinand had shown no signs of
outward aggression as he watched the
cannibal hack away at onions with his
enormous knife maxwell could feel
himself beginning to sweat
after all they didn't call this creature
the cannibal for nothing this was a
monster with a truly horrifying body
count
during previous containment breaches it
had taken enough tranquilizer to put
down two elephants to subdue the
creature but not before multiple agents
quite literally lost their heads in the
process
fernan was able to bite them off with
one huge chomp like he was eating a
drumstick snapping right through the
bone with his incredible tooth and jaw
strength surprisingly when he wasn't on
a violent rampage foundation researchers
had found
scp-082 to be unusually polite and
forthcoming offering the researchers
plenty of information about himself and
his past
the only problem was that almost
everything the creature said was a
complete lie
from his time as a researcher maxwell
knew that there were only a few details
about the creature that could be
ascertained for certain
scp-082 would reliably answer to the
name fernand and genetically ferdinand
was technically human
the means by which ferdinand became so
grotesquely huge strong and
cannibalistic are still unknown
foundation personnel are still looking
into whether it's due to some kind of
anomalous genetic mutation or by more
supernatural means
all we know is that he's big
unpredictable and extremely dangerous
dr robert maxwell sat terrified at the
dining table of
scp-082 listening to fernand's slightly
dull blade chopped through the final
onion which he then tossed into the
boiling soup
fernand had switched the topic of
conversation to one of his favorite
fictional characters
hannibal lecter
of course hannibal the cannibal isn't
quite so fictional to fernan while he's
been shown to be extremely intelligent
in terms of puzzle solving and memory he
seems to have no understanding of the
distinctions between fiction and reality
he assumes all movies and tv shows are a
form of documentary or reality
television and ever since seeing the
silence of the lambs ferdinand has been
eager to meet with dr lecter which he
emphasized to maxwell over and over
since trying to explain the concept of
fiction to ferdinand had never
previously worked maxwell simply told
him that dr lecter is extremely busy at
the moment but will visit whenever he
gets a chance this seemed to satisfy
fernand who placed two large bowls of
steaming soup on the table before
sitting down a little too close to
maxwell he couldn't help but notice that
the giant cannibal was now sitting
within biting distance and as a lowly
d-class nobody would be rushing in to
save him if things went south
fernand began ranting through his
clenched teeth once more occasionally
stopping to consume a hefty spoonful of
onion soup maxwell was sure to do the
same not wanting to seem anything less
than polite but soon the tenor of
ferdinand's rant began to shift
typically the monster spoke french or
heavily accented english
now he was affecting the accent of a
victorian gentleman peppering his speech
with telly ho and the game is afoot
maxwell was confused at first but
quickly realized the game fernand was
playing it's well known that fernan is a
pathological liar who likes to play
numerous characters
changing his mannerisms and clothes
accordingly these personas have included
a vampire big bird andre the giant
foundation researcher dr bright the
incredible hulk alexander the great
captain hook dr frankenstein and
frankenstein's monster and of course in
this case
the iconic fictional detective sherlock
holmes
fearing for his life in this strange
situation dr maxwell did the only thing
he could
play along as fernan reeled off his
holmesian delusions maxwell began to
play the role of dr john watson asking
follow-up questions and complimenting
ferdinand's impeccable deductive
reasoning and it seemed to be working
ferdinand played along too acting as
though the two of them really were
arthur conan doyle's crime-fighting duo
towards the end of their game dr maxwell
was even starting to enjoy it amazed
that his quick thinking was actually
keeping him safe but just then the
cannibal froze as if in a trance he
locked eyes with dr maxwell like a mad
dog that you can't tell if it's going to
bite you or not he saw the creature's
gargantuan teeth separating its huge
jaws stretching open this could surely
only mean one thing dr maxwell winced
and prepared for death cursing that all
of his quick thinking had amounted to
nothing
fernan leaned towards him his gaping maw
with its hot onion scented breath just
inches away from maxwell
and then
he began to sing the cannibal broke into
a raucous victorian pub song happy and
jovial in his moment of terror dr
maxwell had forgotten that this was the
other reason scp-082 opens his
nightmarish jaws
relief washed over him as he knew he was
safe at least for the moment
not long after foundation guards arrived
and escorted him from the cell leaving
the delusional giant to his own devices
back in the so-called palace
the former researcher had done it he had
bested ferdinand the cannibal and
hopefully it would be the last time he'd
ever be face to face with that deranged
giant
unfortunately for dr robert maxwell in a
performance review later that week one
of his superiors remarked that fernand
enjoyed his company and he had done a
great job such a good job in fact that
ferdinand insisted he have dr maxwell
for dinner
or any other meal for that matter
sometime
very soon
now go check out
scp-096 the shy guy and scp-3000
anantashisha for more tales to capture
the imagination from the scp foundation